it's so funny to me that you brought up
Better Call Saul because on the way over
here to uh the podcast Studio I swear to
God this is true I was thinking about
you I like to think about I was looking
forward to this interview
and Bob Odenkirk came to mind because I
think you two have both managed a very
improbable very hard to pull off feat
which is
um you both started in one place and and
you could have been in a great stand-up
if you were just to stand up that could
have been your career and you could be
really proud of it but then you you kept
moving you kept changing you kept
bobbing you kept weaving and I think Bob
Odenkirk did the same thing which is
never said well wait a minute I can't do
this on bombodenkirk I'm from Mr Show
that this isn't something I can do he uh
you know he completely transformed
his career uh and and by the you know
during the pandemic he had become an
action star yeah nobody and I was like
uh I love this movie I totally believe
Bob in it I used to work with him at
Saturday Night Live we had desks next to
each other if you had told me then that
he'd be kicking ass in an action movie
like Jean-Claude Van Damme I'd say uh
well uh no that's just never going to
happen and I think you've done the same
thing well you've you I think you're two
guys that I've known in and seen
witnessed you up close at different
periods in your career and you just keep
saying I'm going this way now and I just
believe I'm going to be able to do it
and then you do it well that's very kind
I don't think you can compare me to Bob
ortonkirk I think you know he's his work
on better call install is so good I
actually
saw Bob Odenkirk for the first time ever
I heard of him was on your show on NBC
Mr show was on but I hadn't watched it I
just seen it Go by on the guide and I
was like that's a feels like a bad title
for a TV show I'm never watching that
then I saw him on your show and he was
so funny yeah and I was really obsessed
with you know that's when I first
started getting obsessed with comedy and
stand up and that's when I started
watching Mr Show and I remember I
recorded it on VHS and brought it to my
friends and I was like you guys gotta
watch this show
so good and then to see even but you
could see back then in those sketches he
was a very good actor right he's always
been a very good Yeller like he's so
good at screaming yeah he's so good and
he was so good he does have a lot of
anger I'm gonna say that right now but
she probably helps him and he's so good
on on Better Call Saul and for me you
know I want to be able to do all the
things I love and and the things you
think you can do sort of keep changing
yeah it's always like you I want to try
and do the next thing that's like
almost impossible for me to do but not
quite I mean I think that's sort of the
goal and it's a very scary thing to like
keep doing that but um I feel honestly
very lucky that there have been people
who thought I could do those things and
sometimes their belief that I could do
it is what allowed me to think I could
do it you can feed off that yeah like
this show Rob Siegel was like I think
you can do this and really that was what
got me to say maybe maybe he's right and
I'm wrong well it's uh welcome to
Chippendales is coming out
um in a week and it's on Hulu and I I
want to see it I I'm a huge fan of yours
and I'm glad that we're now best friends
you really walked into that one no I'm
I'm in I'm here let's uh you don't want
to think about it for a little while no
I'm in okay here it is okay I mean this
is it we're best friends well okay I
gotta make some calls because there's a
couple of people out there and they know
who they are who think they're my best
friend
um Timothy Oliphant knows better he
knows he does it because you know he's
already moved on he's a sociopath
uh but um all the handsome actors have
to be so excited
how can you be that handsome and like
not completely here's what enrages me
about him he's that good looking and
he's also incredibly funny again first
on your show yeah yeah and he's and
that's devastatingly funny and I think
that's not fair it's so unfair I saw him
at a party I hadn't met him and somebody
introduced me to him and I was like
you're very good at panel shows you're
very funny and it was it meant so much
to him he's like wow nobody thinks I'm
like I could do comedy but oh my God
yeah he's he's one of the funniest so
good on your show you guys are so good
together well when you get two really
handsome guys together yeah is this my
thing no it's working oh weird I heard a
weird uh sort of collective sigh
um